little evidence tonight of a bipartisan
awakening following last night's call
for unity in president Trump's first
State of the Union speech chief White
House correspondent John Roberts looks
at the president's efforts to reach
across the aisle and how they were
received good even John Brett could
evening to you you know many times in
the past presidents have hit the road
immediately after the State of the Union
address to sell their policies that were
included in the speech across the nation
president Trump preferred to stay here
at the White House and let the themes of
his speech marinate for a while the
President of the United States President
Trump got high marks from Republicans
for his State of the Union address the
speech from which he extended an olive
branch to Democrats tonight I am
extending an open hand to work with
members of both parties Democrats and
Republicans to protect our citizens of
every background color religion and
Creed finding a fix for daca is the most
urgent priority protections for
so-called dreamers and on March the 5th
president Trump last night presented
what he called a down the middle
compromise a detailed proposal that
should be supported by both parties as a
fair compromise one where nobody gets
everything they want but where our
country gets the critical reforms it
needs and must have the deal offers a
path to citizenship for 1.8 million
dreamers three times the number of
people President Obama protected but
Democrats say the trade-offs over border
security chain migration in the visa
lottery is something they just won't
swallow it was dangerous what he said
last night and it is instilled fear as I
say over and over what he is doing
brings tears to the eyes of the Statue
of Liberty and it's still fear in the
hearts of people who are concerned about
by dreamers it is also time to rebuild
our crumbling infrastructure President
Trump also hopes to build bipartisan
support for a 1.5 trillion dollar
infrastructure program every federal
dollar should be leveraged by partnering
with state and local governments and
where
period tapping into private sector
investment to permanently fix the
infrastructure deficit but Democrats who
are on the record is supporting
infrastructure renewal blew a raspberry
at that one - calling the proposal quote
puny President Trump tried to put a
fresh coat of paint on a failing
presidency it didn't work Americans see
through the rhetoric and understand the
reality Democrats sat on their hands
much of the night refusing to
acknowledge items like a historic low
for african-american unemployment and
corporate bonuses for employees a
byproduct of tax reform the president
Trump highlighted today inviting workers
from five states to the Oval Office we
have some companies that have announced
3000 bonuses and in some cases even more
some have given raises to the minimum
wage up to 12 13 14 and even $15
divisions with Democrats continued today
over the White House's planned release
of the Republican FISA memo in a radio
interview with Fox and Friends Brian
Kilmeade chief of staff John Kelly
saying the sooner it's out the better
that'll be released here pretty quick I
think and Everett the whole world
concealed there were some moments during
the State of the Union that brought both
sides to their feet
Congress paying tribute to many of the
guests invited by the White House
including a North Korean defector a
tortured amputee who's raised crutches
and defiance became the face of North
Korean oppression last night and some
late developing news with their FISA
memo a senior administration official
tells Fox new is that late yesterday
before the president left for the State
of the Union address five career
officials from the FBI came over to
discuss the memo and view it with the
chief of staff John Kelly the FBI
official or at least FBI officials had
seen an earlier version of that they
were concerned about the contents of it
particularly in the subject of sources
and methods I'm told the version that
they saw last night had been changed
somewhat from the version that they were
concerned about earlier but yet the FBI
still went ahead and released that
statement of concern Brett so we'll keep
chasing this one for a year okay more on
this with the panel John Roberts live in
the North Lawn John thanks